now before we get into some of the minut
details of using our physics engine
let's take a minute and go through our
wish list of what we like our physics
engine to do for us and why it makes our
lives a lot simpler the first thing is
that we'd like to be able to create
physics objects for each of our game
entities that needs them we'd also like
to be able to update the physics engine
each frame or rather we'd like to be
able to allow the physics engine to
update itself and take care of most of
the work for us we'd also like to be
able to fire off collision events
between different physics objects and
then respond to them arbitrarily and
finally we'd really like to be able to
pull updated position information for
each of our game physics objects each
frame that means effectively that we can
use the physics engines calculations to
feed position information into our
rendering engine for drawing next frame
so to accomplish all of this for grits
we decided to go with physics engine
called box2d